[Music]
a vaccine is the world's best hope of
overcoming the covid19 pandemic
more than 20 vaccines are in development
globally but as scientists move closer
to success
possible breakthrough in the development
of a coronavirus vaccine
there's a problem
a growing number of people say they
won't take a vaccine
i don't want to inject anything like
this into my body this is linked to
declining trust in scientific experts
and political leaders
[Music]
problems brought into even sharper focus
by the pandemic
and fueled by a spiraling emphademic
anybody who has trusted the president
has been lied to
and many people like my dad have paid
with their life this crisis of trust
could have catastrophic consequences so
what can be done to rebuild trust in
vaccines
and to protect the world from future
disasters all vaccine advocates need to
be more tech savvy
we have science and evidence and right
and fact on our side
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the front line in the race to
find a covid19 vaccine
professor jonathan heaney is one of
those leading the charge
it has very much been a race against
time and sometimes i wish time could
stand still
the professor has been developing
vaccines for over 25 years
now we have representatives of those
viruses that are closely related to
sars1 or sars2
but finding one to fight a virus which
has brought the world to its knees
feels different i do know people who've
had kovid
and it's a terrible terrible death it is
an agonizing disease
this project in cambridge is about to
begin clinical human trials
and the stakes could not be higher if we
don't have a vaccine
we'll be stuck in this lifestyle of
isolation social distancing masks for a
long long time
[Music]
for a vaccine to immunize populations
effectively against covid19
around 70 percent of people need to be
willing to take it
trust is absolutely critical if only
part of
the population is on board we're never
going to bring this virus to its knees
and control this epidemic
[Music]
but in the rich world especially polls
suggest that persuading people to take
vaccines may be as difficult as
producing them in the first place
[Applause]
many of these protesters belong to a
growing minority
who believe a covert 19 vaccine would
actually be harmful to their health
do i worry about vaccinations this one
in particular yes definitely
it's been rushed and imposed on us and i
you know i want to have my choice and i
don't want to inject anything like this
into my body and into my children's body
some here see a vaccine as part of a
wider government conspiracy
to exaggerate the dangers of covid19
many of these people have lost trust in
their government
and we will not give up until we get the
truth we are not going to stand for
being lied to by our governments by
people that we
should trust they want us to trust us
but we can't trust them
the views being expressed here are
extreme and belong to a minority
the proportion of the global population
opposed to vaccines generally is
estimated to be well
under 10 percent
but anti-vaxxers as they're often called
are a vocal minority
and their views are increasingly
influencing broader society
distrust can be infectious
a poll carried out in america in
september found that only 36
of adults said they would take a vaccine
when one becomes available
with 64 saying they wouldn't take one or
weren't sure
[Music]
in another survey under four-fifths of
people
in 16 countries responded positively to
the idea of taking a covid19 vaccine
if proven safe and effective
in the context of covid i think empathy
is absolutely crucial
professor heidi larson is an
anthropologist
and a leading expert on why significant
sections of the global population feel
hesitant about vaccines
she says a failure to confront the root
causes of vaccine hesitancy
as she calls it is driving more of these
people towards anti-vaccination views
the majority of the public that is
questioning their hesitant they're
anxious
these are people who have genuine
questions
who are open to vaccination but are
feeling they're not
getting their answers and then migrate
more to the more anti-end
that seem more acknowledging their
concerns
endorsing their concerns professor
larson argues
that one of the historic problems has
been a failure by the medical
establishment
to listen to the concerns of parents who
have doubts about inoculating their
children
a lot of parents feel like they're being
judged called
names for even asking questions
and that's not at all been helpful in
trying to support people in their
decision making
and positive sentiments towards a
vaccine
it's really fundamentally about trust
relational trust
breaking news testing has been paused
for one of the leading candidates
developed by oxford university
in september a volunteer from a leading
covid19 vaccine trial
was admitted to hospital and the project
was temporarily halted
professor larson says an opportunity was
missed to build trust with the public
i wish in the news instead of
just this is normal process safety
events happen
we're taking care of it that the voice
of a participant said i appreciate the
care
and the attention that the clinical team
gave to me during this
uncertain time the message is sent that
there is a caring
team that they're not just putting
vaccines in people to count numbers and
get to the perfect vaccine
that there is human empathy in this
the medical and pharmaceutical
professions have been far from immune to
missteps during the history of vaccines
and this has helped fuel today's climate
of vaccine hesitancy and opposition
not least the legacy of a british doctor
named andrew wakefield
in 1998 he published research in a
highly respected medical journal
claiming there was a link between a
measles vaccine and autism
wakefield and colleagues altered facts
about patients in their studies
but his research turned out to be highly
compromised
studies have shown no connection between
the mmr
vaccination and autism
the journal eventually retracted the
research and wakefield was struck off
the medical register in the uk
in 2010 but many members of the public
continue to see wakefield as a credible
expert
this guy has been set up it's nothing
but lies
and millions across the world still have
reservations about taking the measles
vaccine
it's symptomatic of a wider decline in
trust in traditional experts
and governments in rich world countries
[Music]
[Music]
dr jonathan kennedy is an expert in
global public health
and has investigated the link between
trust and government and authorities
and hesitancy about vaccines in this
class
we're going to talk about the question
of how to think critically
about global health
dr kennedy analyzed voting data and
surveys on public confidence in vaccines
across 14 countries he found a broad
pattern
where levels of electoral support for
populist parties were higher
levels of mistrust in vaccines also
tended to be higher
populist sentiment this distrust of
elites and experts
isn't just isn't just isolated in
politics the forces driving
scientific populism are all very similar
to those that drive political populism
[Applause]
dr kennedy argues there's a strong
relationship between vaccine hesitancy
and political social and economic crisis
at a time when trust between people and
politicians has been breaking down
a number of countries have seen a
resurgence of measles
how dare you yes you racist it certainly
wasn't a coincidence that the uk
last summer lost its measles-free status
how about that at a time where there was
massive conflict over brexit
during the covid19 pandemic the response
of governments has further decreased
trust in public health experts and
politicians
not least in some countries with
populist leaders
the test and trace isn't improved
significantly
it could be a second wave in britain
under prime minister boris johnson's
leadership
public health guidance has changed
constantly and
confusingly we're constantly working to
improve that delivery system buying ppe
from
around the world creating a sense that
the government is failing
and incompetent in a huge policy
reversal
affecting hundreds of thousands of
pupils what's more
senior political figures have failed to
follow their own
health guidelines trust in the british
government is a reliable source of
information about coronavirus
fell from 67 in april to 44
in august
don't let it dominate you
don't be afraid of it in america
false information about the virus has
flowed from a president whose contempt
for truth
has done more than anything else to sow
distrust in politicians and experts
one month ago today president trump said
that the coronavirus was quote
dying out i've read a lot about hydroxy
i happen to think that it has an impact
and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute
researchers at cornell university
analyzed 38 million
english language articles about the
pandemic
they found president trump was the
single largest driver of misinformation
around kovid 19.
this is me and my mom and my dad in new
york
after i graduated from college for some
this has had lethal consequences in june
christine urquisa lost her father mark
to covet 19. 65 year old mark
was a lifelong republican voter and
trump supporter from arizona
he died after arizona's governor
reopened the state
encouraged by the president when the
governor and the president went
um around pushing a reopening strategy
and saying to the public it was safe
if you didn't have an underlying health
condition it was
safe to go out resume normal activities
my dad listened and thought it was safe
mark contracted kovid 19 after visiting
a karaoke bar
his daughter says placing trust in his
political leaders
proved a fatal mistake
both the president and the governor of
arizona
are on record through that time
downplaying the virus
anybody who has trusted the president
has been lied to
has been misled and many people
like my dad have paid with their life
as a result
while the actions of populist
politicians have undermined trust in
public health advice and
institutions there is another factor
which has driven this trend
the unprecedented speed at which
misinformation can spread
in february the world health
organization warned of twin dangers
a global pandemic but also an infodemic
a crisis in accurate public health
information
these insufferable globalist elitists
like bill gates he tells us we need a
nationwide shutdown for months
this foundation is leading the charge to
lower
the world's population much of this
infidemic is concentrated
online social media users who may not
hold strong views about particular
issues
can rapidly be exposed to misleading and
extremist content
folks i think they're trying to force a
vaccine on all of us
[Music]
neil johnson is a professor of physics
at george washington university
his research shows how fake news can
gain the upper
hand in the online battle for hearts and
minds
what we expected to find was that
there'd be a core
of communities maybe public health
agencies
that we're promoting vaccines and
establishment health thinking
and that around this central strong core
there'd be
other opinions sort of extremes but
that's not what we found
we found that that was actually sort of
inside out
professor johnson's team mapped
conversations on facebook
about vaccines between 100 million
people all over the world
they discovered that misinformation was
exerting more influence than accurate
information
in some sense it's almost like a network
of trust and if they flipped either way
of course they could
become red they could become blue and
that completely changes the battlefield
on this battlefield map red represents
facebook pages and members
with anti-vaccination views and their
spread over time
blue represents pages and members with
pro-vaccination views
while green signifies the all-important
groups of people who are undecided
the undecided greens are more engaged
with the red
anti-vaccination clusters than the
pro-vaccination blues
the reds they are completely entangled
with the greens they're not shores the
communities of pet lovers
parents groups organic blueberry lovers
the ones that can tip the balance one
way or the other the worry is
as we see the greens and the reds
entangle what we're really seeing is
a beginning of an entanglement of trust
away from establishment
science trust is the glue because
in the end when we trust the community
if they happen to start talking about
vaccines which is something that i don't
ordinarily think about
i will follow them in their thinking
this entanglement matters research has
found that online exposure to recent
misinformation about a covid19 vaccine
may significantly affect intent to take
one
and professor johnson believes this kind
of content
will continue to spread online with the
result that anti-vaccination sentiment
could become the majority view
within a few years red with the
concerned greens will rise to
essentially dominate that space and
it'll be very
hard to reverse that so something
different needs to be done now
social media platforms have increased
their efforts to stop the spread of
untruths about vaccines and kovid 19.
in april facebook put warning labels on
about 50 million
pieces of content related to the virus
the platform partnered with reliable
sources like the who and the nhs
and in october facebook banned
anti-vaccine
ads yet campaigners argue
the platform isn't going far enough and
is failing to take down the majority of
harmful content about vaccinations
more broadly facebook's own algorithm
undermines
efforts to stem the tide of the
infidemic says fadi kuran
from the online political campaign group
avaz
facebook's algorithm is sabotaging
the efforts of the platform to fix the
misinformation problem
it cares about keeping individuals
engaged interested
and online sensationalist outrageous
content
not the cdc guidelines but q anon
for example gets more engagement and
hence the algorithm pushes it up in your
news feed
one solution might be to detoxify the
algorithm
what facebook isn't doing is redesigning
its algorithm
redesigning its business model to ensure
that it's not continuing to amplify this
content
and this does not mean that the
algorithm should be designed to censor
content
it just means that the algorithm would
downgrade instead of
putting this malicious content at the
top of one's news feed
the platform would make sure that it is
at the bottom of the news feed
social media platforms could save lives
they have the power this is a problem
that mark zuckerberg and jack dorsey
could literally say we're going to solve
this right now
yet redesigning algorithms and
tightening regulations on tech companies
is unlikely to get to the root causes of
mistrust in vaccines
to do that health bodies and experts
will need to be proactive about building
relationships with the public
in person and especially online
according to doctors at this pediatric
practice in pittsburgh
the key to tackling distrust and
misinformation is to fight fire
with fire hello this is a yucky doctor
coming in how are you guys doing today
i'm doing okay while it might look like
any other children's surgery
the kids plus practice has its own
in-house video production suite
getting messages out to patients
constantly and quickly
vaccine advocates are online using our
voices
not the same way we are in the office
we're saving lives
we're protecting them against myth
truths
and disinformation that can literally
kill people i think all vaccine
advocates need to be more tech savvy
kids plus routinely post evidence-based
videos and information
about vaccines on all major social media
platforms
i'll start things off until we see our
questions start rolling in again hello
to tick-tock hello to facebook live
and this presence allows them to respond
to questions from parents and families
who feel uninformed and concerned
our parents our families are living
their entire lives
right here on their phones on their
tablets on their laptops their desktops
if people hear good evidence-based
information
before they hear the miss and
disinformation that
miss and disinformation is much less
likely to affect them what you are
essentially doing
is inoculating them against that
[ __ ]
before it can take root in them
these doctors also argue that it's vital
to take on the stream of highly
organized and targeted viral attacks
from anti-vaccine forces the reality of
online
vaccine advocacy right now is if you
post it they will come
the anti-vaxxers will find you and they
will
attack you they want to terrorize
providers
into silence it's a challenge the
practice knows all about
together we can prevent cancer in your
children
in 2017 kids plus released a video
promoting an
hpv vaccine that prevents cancer
and faced a barrage of hostility they
attacked our post
they attacked our facebook page they
attacked the private pages of our
families and our patients who defended
us on our post
they came right after our reputation
kidsplus has since created a toolkit for
health professionals
and built a digital cavalry of global
vaccine advocates
who can quickly come to the aid of those
under fire from anti-vaccine forces
now as a vaccine for kovid-19 grows
closer
kids plus and it's self-styled keyboard
crusaders
are stealing themselves for a bitter but
all-important new fight
there's no vaccine yet there's no hurt
immunity for covid
and look this is what life is like
without herd immunity this is what life
is like
without vaccines past evidence suggests
some people
could end up taking vaccines after
saying they might not
but herd immunity to covid19 may require
around 70
take-up of a vaccine and just a six
percentage point decline in acceptance
could endanger this goal and for many
alarm bells are ringing we're losing in
large part because
the anti-vaccine forces are much more
passionate and organized than
we are there are far fewer of them
than there are of us we have science and
evidence and
right and fact on our side that's how we
win
hello i'm slovaya chankova the economist
healthcare correspondent
if you'd like to learn more about the
race to develop an effective
covet 19 vaccine click on the link
opposite
thank you for watching and please don't
forget to subscribe